mesdames et messieurs bonsoir je suis
très heureux d'être parmi vous est ce
que jusque là tout va bien alors je vais
essayer en 17 minutes 52 de vous faire
le lien entre le thème de la soirée qui
s'était donc l'esprit critique et la
question de l'obéissance la question de
la soumission à l'autorité alors tout
commence avec la génialissime hannah
arendt femme absolument extraordinaire
philosophe allemande exilé aux états
unis depuis très longtemps à ce moment
là et qui en 1960 propose ses services
au journal le new yorker pour faire
basiquement la pigiste la journaliste
elle propose de couvrir le procès d'un
adolf eichmann à jérusalem
évidemment le journal accepte vous
imaginez bien et la voilà qui se
retrouvent à écrire des articles sur ce
à quoi elle assiste pendant ce procès
est dans un de ses articles à l'écrit
cette chose incroyable elle dit je n'ai
pas vu un homme sanguinaire
j'ai pas vu un barbare j'ai vu un homme
insignifiant qui a juste perdu le
pouvoir de penser qui a juste perdu le
pouvoir de penser imaginer le choc quand
une philosophe juive d'origine allemande
dit ce genre de choses à peine 15 ans
après la seconde guerre mondiale ce qui
fit cas là elle s'est beaucoup expliqué
évidemment l'objectif n'était pas de
justifier mais d'expliquer ce propos
elle l'a incarné dans une théorie qui
s'appelle la théorie de la banalité du
mal qui pour moi ne s'applique pas aux
grands chefs nazis mais par contre
s'applique à tous les soldats ou tous
les officiers allemands et l'idée c'est
de démontrer que en quelque sorte quand
un contexte et puissant quand un
contexte je peux emmener tout un groupe
de personnes dans un certain sens
effectivement on peut perdre son esprit
critique à perdre le sens commun et on
peut finir par se déshabituer à la
capacité à penser
et quand on perd la capacité à penser
bas on perd son esprit critique ce qui
revient en quelques sortes à une forme
d'obéissance
automatique à une pensée unique il ya
une pensée subit alors cette pensée
subit elle peut nous amener à dire des
choses qui sont contraires à nos valeurs
mais ça peut être très très puissant
parce que quand vous l'exposer à
l'échelle d'une société ou à l'échelle
d'une culture sur le tour en plus ça
peut même avoir un impact très lourd sur
nos choix sur nos décisions sur nos
actes et y compris sur des actes les
plus graves
je range propre du terme où les plus
définitif par exemple la parentalité
c'est intéressant est ce qu'on peut
imaginer que l'absence d'esprit critique
ou l'absence de capacité à penser puisse
nous amener à avoir des enfants sans
même se poser la question de savoir si
j'ai envie d'avoir des enfants
ça paraît incroyable comme une décision
incroyable de toute une vie
et puis quand vous consultez les
psychologues les psychothérapeutes qui
vous disent pas des gens comme ça dans
mon en séance j'en ai plein les gens qui
viennent parce qu'ils ont été conçus par
des parents qui ne se sont pas posé la
question de pourquoi il voulait être ta
range en dit plus incroyable mais parce
que la société est faite ainsi
quel tabou pour quelqu'un de dire j'ai
pas envie d'avoir d'enfants encore pire
pour une femme que pour un homme vous
noterez bien d'accord alors on peut en
arriver là on peut arriver à ne pas se
poser la question
alors on fait son premier enfant autour
de la trentaine parce qu'on sent bien
que les gens nous disaient il s'agirait
que ça avance parce que l'horloge tourne
et puis une fois qu'on a fait son
premier enfant ont fait ce fameux
complexe post partum
on appelle le baby blues connaissait le
baby blues
alors je dis pas que ça n'existe pas il
ya quand même un truc intéressant c'est
que la france est le pays dans lequel il
ya plus de baby blues et le pays dans
lequel on en parle le plus alors c'est
intéressant est ce que on est en quelque
sorte dans une forme de soumission à une
autorité psychique qui nous imposerait
d'être en dépression
quand on a eu un enfant j'étais pas que
ça n'existe pas je dis que si on le
répète tout le temps on accélère on
augmente les chances que ça se produise
alors une fois qu'on a fait son premier
enfant on est tranquille deux en un
puis au bout d'eux on nous dit bon allez
va falloir vous y remettre parce qu'un
enfant unique c'est pas bien vous allez
faire un enfant un peu égoïste qui se
mélange rap a donc faut faire un
deuxième absolument puis alors si ça
peut être un sexe différent du premier
ça serait super bien on faire deuxième
repose par tonne un peu moins fort hein
et puis une fois qu'on a fait le
deuxième alors là ça change on doit par
contre là maintenant vous arrêtez les
gars hein parce que la planète est en
train de partir en sauce parce que c'est
pas bien raisonnable équilibre des temps
de vie la carrière tout ça le logement
bon alors 2 vous en faites deux et puis
ça s'arrête là quand même incroyable
si vous regardez les chiffres de la
sociologie
c'est terrible on fait son premier
enfant en france à 35 ans ont fait son
deuxième enfant à 34 ans et enfin en
france 2,05 enfants peu déprimant alors
maintenant on fait le troisième à 41 45
parce que oui je voulais vous dire il ya
encore une autre obligation c'est le
démon de midi tous les hommes autour de
la quarantaine sont traversés par une
espèce de pulsion libidinale quasi
génétique qui consiste à faire que c'est
comme ça bas et je suis désolé c'est
démon de midi
alors on fait un petit troisième
d'accord vers 45
il y en a plein des comme ça la crise de
l'adolescence c'est génial pourquoi
pourquoi faudrait-il nécessairement
qu'on soit en crise d'adolescence
oui alors bien sûr on est fatigué on
grandit les boutons sortent l'appareil
pousse bon oui pas simple je dis pas que
c'est simple mais dès qu'un enfant de 11
ans pour la première fois lève les yeux
au ciel
les deux parents disent ah ça y est fait
à crise d'adolescence
est-ce qu'il a le choix cet enfant ce
qui peut faire autre chose que de faire
une crise d'adolescence
pas tellement et puis le tabou ultime
après c'est le départ à la retraite
quand vous partez à la retraite qu'est
ce que tu vas faire de ta retraite
bah rien je vais demander un non non non
tu vas être malheureux je te connais
c'est quand même terrible quoi la
naissance jusqu'au bout ces injonctions
espèce de soumission à l'autorité ce que
je me pose la question à abandonner
c'est compliqué voyez que ça peut être
très très puissant
y compris sur soi même réfléchissons à
ce qu'on appelle l'autocritique
l'autocritique sait se remettre en cause
là c'est en quelque sorte ce désobéir
désobéir à qui honda dans l'estimé de
soi
pas facile de se désunir parce que
normalement quand on est on est pas
atteints d'une pathologie mentale quand
on se lève le matin on est plutôt guidé
par l' envie de passer une bonne journée
qu'une mauvaise et pour passer une bonne
journée il vaut mieux avoir une image de
soi satisfaisante
ça fait pas de nous des pervers 1,9
narcissique c'est juste que c'est plus
agréable a mécaniquement se remettre en
cause c'est s'autoriser à penser qu'on
n'est pas la personne c'est merveilleux
ce qu'on pense qu'on est
vous voyez bien que critique et être
dans l'esprit critique c'est une
capacité à désobéir
or la société nous conduit à obéir tout
le temps
regardez l'horoscope c'est intéressant
le l'horoscope une étude scientifique a
montré que 75 % des verbes utilisé dans
l'horoscope ne sont pas au présent de
l'indicatif mais à l'impératif prenez
vous en main
expliquez moi en quoi c'est une
prédiction c'est un ordre pour vous
donne vous vous brossez les dents le
matin on vous dit prenez vous en main
c'est un ordre lavez vous les mains
quand vous allez au quand vous allez au
aux toilettes
moi je fasse mes journées dans les tours
à la défense c'est pas des écoles
maternelles pour autant dans les
escaliers il ya écrit
tenez la rampe
vous vous rendez compte tenez la rampe
mesurer le nombre d'injonctions est
d'ordre que vous qui vous tombe sur la
tête jour et nuit compliqué d'avoir
l'esprit critique quand on est dans cet
esprit là alors donc le lien il
étouffait désobéir avoir un esprit
critique c'est s'engager dans la voie de
la désobéissance alors il ya deux
auteurs en psychologie sociale qui ont
incarné cette pensée le premier set et
aux doors adorno qui en 1954 publie une
étude
un livre qui s'appelle la personnalité
autoritaire et chose intéressante il
s'appuie sur des données empiriques
il a fait passer des milliers de
questionnaires et sur la base des
résultats il a mené des entretiens en
fonction des résultats qu'il a trouvé et
alors ils trouvent des corrélations
intéressante il se rend compte qu'il ya
effectivement un profil de personnalité
être autoritaire
ce sont des gens qui ont une pensée
radicale rapide qu'on des positions
surtout des opinions sur tout tranché
pas forcément pas forcément argumenté
premières découvertes intéressantes
je vois que ça sourit on se dit ah on
dirait qu'ils parlent de moi première
découverte à tous alors celle inverse
première découverte intéressante il y
aurait une corrélation entre des
opinions mais qui sont liées
sémantiquement par exemple il constate
que les gens qui ont une opinion très
sexiste sont aussi une opinion très
homophobe jusqu'à la sas tiens on voit
qu'il ya un lien entre les deux bien je
dis pas que c'est bien mais c'est lié
puis ensuite ils trouvent des
corrélations plus intéressantes les gens
très très sexiste adore la police
là on se dit bon alors ça veut dire que
c'est pas forcément liés par le sens ça
peut être lié par le style cognitifs et
l'origine identifiés par hard par adorno
et de cette pensée autoritaire c'est
l'éducation dogmatique sait comment les
parents nous ont transmis le monde
comment ils nous ont expliqué à quoi
ressemblait le monde et ce qu'ils n'ont
fait façon dogmatique ou pas d'accord
et ça c'est extrêmement intéressant si
vous dites à un enfant très tôt écoute
coco c'est simple dieu existe point la
reverse est un vrai dieu n'existe pas
point vous dites pas l'enfant réfléchi
vous lui dites le monde il est comme ça
à un moment donné on y est bien
mon plaisir à moi est ce qu'il est à
contredire will i am aligne alors je
m'aligne et en même temps si je me
rebelle être critique n'est pas
contredire si je me rebelle une personne
qui est toujours dans la rébellion vous
avez forcément autres de vous des
adolescents qui vous disent non à tout
vous dites un truc idiot non non je pas
d'accord si vous vous révélez
systématiquement la rébellion c'est de
la soumission en fait puisque vous êtes
en miroir se rebeller systématiquement
c'est se soumettre avant l'esprit
critique n'est pas contredire c'est
développer une pensée alternative avoir
la liberté d'imaginer une troisième voie
possible à la réflexion alors le
deuxième moteur qui a encore mieux
incarner le travail c'est stanley
milgram qu'à mener des travaux très
célèbre en psychologie sociale
expérience dit des chocs électriques
je vous le fais vite cette année le
grain mais une annonce dans le journal
pour recruter des personnes pour
participer à une expérience prétendument
sur la mémoire les gens s'inscrivent ils
viennent par deux ont fait un faux de
tirage au sort qui détermine un
professeur qui va devoir faire apprendre
à un élève des couples de mots si
l'élève ne mémorise pas bien les couples
de mots hymne punition et la punition
est un choc électrique
premier choc 15 volts ça picote mais
tout va bien
deuxième choc 30 28 45 puis 68 75
jusqu'à 450 c'est à dire jusqu'à un choc
mortel
il se trouve que le vrai sujet une
expérience qui nous intéresse c'est le
professeur parce que l'élève est un
acteur qui fait semblant
en fait y'a pas de courant électrique
qui passe je conteste en vrai c'est la
capacité de ce professeur un individu
normal comme vous et moi à obéir à un
ordre totalement barbares contraire à
ses valeurs
simplement parce qu'un scientifique en
blouse blanche de l'université de yale
avec le badge et labarde lui dit tu dois
le faire
la science exige que tu le fasses et
milgram ne sait absolument pas ce qui ce
qui va trouver quand il lance expérience
on né en 1963
on est juste après effectivement ces
publications d'un arendt donc ils
veulent tester lui
et comme il sait pas ce que ça va ce que
ça va donner il soumet son protocole à
40 psychiatre qui eut une époque ont une
grille d'analysé de la barbarie qui est
purement individuelle la psychologie en
1960 c'est pour tuer quelqu'un il faut
être psychopathe point bas mais il se
dit c'est un emile g est ce qu'on peut
imaginer que pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale il y avait des milliers de
soldats allemands qui étaient des
psychopathes banon tant qu'il ya autre
chose
c'est probablement le contexte et les
psychiatres sont formels ils disent
personne n'ira au dessus de 150 volts
parce qu'à 150 volts c'est un moment
crucial dans l'expérience de stanley
milgram où l'élève fait semblant d'avoir
tellement mal qui dit au professeur
arrêté j'ai mal je voudrais arrêter
l'expérience et les psychiatres 10 banon
partir du moment où l'élève va demander
aux professeurs d'arrêter ça va créer
une dissonance tellement forte dans le
professeur que ça va nous donner un
alibi pour arrêter et là il va pouvoir
dire à l'expérimentateur je suis désolé
j'arrête parce qu'il a mal et je veux
pas me faire souffrir 150 volts
trois ans après 450 personnes après le
choc moyens attribués par les sujets à
cette expérience et de le choc le taux
pardon de personnes qui ont attribué le
choc maximum de 450 volts et de 63%
expérience répliqué dans les années 70
en europe dans un environnement qui est
par un laboratoire c'est à dire dans un
hôpital dans toutes sortes de pays avec
des répliques qui sont encore un peu
secrète aujourd'hui mais qui ont encore
lieu depuis les années 2000 on a
toujours grosso modo deux tiers de gens
qui obéissent ils obéissent à cause de
trois choses et c'est là que je veux en
venir
parce qu'il faut trouver l'objet de
cette conférence et c'est vous dire il
va falloir trouver un équilibre entre
bien comment un éco système peut
fonctionner avec une structure
d'autorité quelques est nécessaire et
comment en même temps cette structure
d'autorité doit laisser un espace à
l'esprit critique alors s'adonner g fait
40 va version de son expérience dans
lequel il teste différentes variables
première variable importante
la question de la légitimité cette année
milgram démontre que
si l'ordre émane d'une autorité légitime
quelle qu'elle soit ça peut être de la
légitimité religieuse idéologique
scientifique parental si cette autorité
légitime on va experts exploser le taux
d'obéissance
parce que j'ai confiance et il crée
effectivement une condition
expérimentale où il met un
expérimentateur qui est pas du tout un
chercheur de yens mais un gars qui est
tiré au sort aussi prétendument et là le
taux d'obéissance passe de 63 20 % si
j'ai pas confiance dans l'autorité
j'arrête d'obéir voyez bien que c'est
intéressant la légitimité de l'autorité
deuxième variable importante la cohésion
de cette autorité dans une version qui a
été rendu à ses célèbres dans le film
d'henri verneuil ikonika arrivait à 150
vols qui est un deuxième
expérimentateurs qui rentre et qui
simule une altercation avec le premier
en mode écoute et j'ai vu le gala les
chocs électriques il n'a pas l'air bien
il faudrait arrêter ils font semblant
évidemment le premier le fou à la porte
en disant c'est moi qui dirige laissez
moi faire et là on dit au professeur
excusez nous reprenons à 7 secondes la
100 % des professeurs arrête
l'expérience à partir du mot je perçois
une faille dans la cohésion de
l'autorité je m'engouffre dans la faille
je fais exploser l'autorité et je peut
désobéir
c'est ce que vos enfants font quand ils
veulent obtenir un truc ils vont voir un
des deux parents pour dire est ce que tu
veux bien que je fasse ça non par
l'autre parent est ce que tu veux bien
que je fasse ça oui terminé vous êtes
mort
s'il ya conflit dans l'autorité si on
n'est pas d'accord
l'enfant a tout compris et après qu'est
ce qui va en jouer un de ces conflits
entre les parents vous étiez pas que
vous étiez pas d'accord tout à l'heure
quand
oui bien troisième variable importante
la plus importante
la question de la responsabilisation
milgram fait la démonstration que plus
je mets la personne obéissante dans un
état agentique c'est à dire comme un
état d' agents d'exécution qui ne
réfléchit pas et qui n'est pas
responsabilisés par ses actes plus je
génère de l'obéissance dans une version
où on donne une responsabilité très
forte au professeur le taux d'obéissance
tombe à 10 % et dans une version où on
lui enlève toute forme de responsabilité
morale juridique ou quoi que ce soit le
taux d'obéissance remonte à 92% en
conclusion vous voyez comment s'y
prendre la vérité est toujours quasiment
toujours une question d'intervalle
comment je crée dans un écosystème quel
qu'il soit la famille l'entreprise la
société en général un intervalle
d'intelligence avec une structure qui
rassure parce que l'autorité ça rassure
d'une certaine façon respecter des
règles et des normes
ça rassure si on partage un langage
commun ou les blagounette parce que ça
rassure ça fait du bien
et en même temps comment ne pas être
conformiste comment générer l'esprit
d'auto critique
il faut créer donc une autorité dans cet
intervalle qu'ils soient légitimes sans
être pour autant infaillible
ne pensez pas que vous serez de bons
parents si vous paraît c'est parfait
admettez que vous vous trompez être
cohésive sans être dogmatique et enfin
être responsabilisant sans être
anxiogène le bon manager c'est celui qui
autorise les membres de son équipe à
être autonome c'est-à-dire à prendre des
risques mais je peux pas dire prend des
risques mais si tu te trompes ça va
tomber la sanction ça marche pas voilà
les trois clés pour être dans cet
intervalle
moi aussi pour pas me tromper j'ai écrit
on a commencé avec un arène la
génialissime on rêve finir avec m
écoutez bien ce qu'elle écrit à 1958
c'est justement pour préserver ce qui
est neuf et révolutionnaire dans chaque
enfant que l'éducation doit être
conservatrices
si vous ajoutez votre esprit critique
vous vous dites mais celle inverse de ce
qui vient de nous dire pendant 20
minutes
en fait pas du tout mais je vous laisse
y réfléchir et je vous souhaite une très
bonne foi